non-minimalists
does letting go of stuff help release
anxiety
my parents just sold their house so i'm
back in my home state of minnesota
minimizing all my old things i can't
justify
or afford shipping everything to
california
and now my anxiety is all over the place
well here's the thing my my short answer
and then we can
we can unpack this a little bit our
material possessions
are our material possessions are a
physical manifestation of our inner
state
amen and so so if there's too much stuff
outside then there's too much going on
inside get your appendix taken out
[Laughter]
that's exactly what i'm saying here man
josh you are so wise
but but that too much is perspectival
right because the thing
if it's too much for me might be just
enough for carissa and so
if there's too much for you outside if
it's stressing you out
that is usually an indicator that
there's something going on in here
and it is manifesting outwardly in these
these physical
possessions so i would also say though
getting rid of too much stuff at once
can also trigger
anxiety it's like being pushed from a
plane versus skydiving
right if you've gone skydiving before
yes one time
you're right and brother moment talked
into it it wasn't so spur of the moment
that you were just pushed out of the
plane that's true
you felt better about the skydiving
experience than if
uh when we got on plane this thursday if
i just were to push you out on our way
to alabama yes
you felt much better because you had
prepared for it accordingly emotionally
psychologically whatever
it can still be terrifying but not
nearly as terrifying
as if you weren't prepared for even if i
pushed you out of the plane
uh and on the way to alabama with a
parachute
you're still going to be like what is
going on this is terrifying
and and so i guess what i'm really
trying to say to chris is is yes you
need to
to let go mentally as well you need to
be prepared
in here before you let go of the things
outwardly but you'll never be
completely prepared if you're waiting
until you're a hundred percent
comfortable with letting go
you'll never let go of anything because
part of the letting go process
is about embracing the discomfort
carissa
here's what i'd say the more we detach
from things that don't add value to our
lives
the calmer the freer and the lighter we
feel
i mean i i can't even tell you man when
just going through that packing party i
didn't even get rid
of everything i just packed it all up
right and i already felt
much lighter like sitting in a room and
uh getting out my laptop that's one of
the first things i unpacked and of
course and i got to unpack the internet
and i'm sitting there uh working on the
coffee table and there's no
tv in front of me there's no uh clutter
sitting over in the corner
no distractions no distractions man i
mean it's it is an automatic yes
absolutely like the more you let go the
freer and lighter you feel now
anything taken too far can can be bad
right
so uh please don't just run the dumpster
and start throwing everything out
yeah but when you let things that's what
i'll say is that when you let things
uh go deliberately yes the freer and
lighter that you feel
yeah because you can do it in a way that
is not intentional you can
uh and that can be that could be a huge
mistake yeah and it could produce way
more anxiety now there's some people get
that to the other side i mean i think of
the couple who
came up to us in philadelphia and said
their house burned down and
and they had a dumpster fire because
they were letting go of too much stuff
they didn't plan for but then they
overnight became like extreme minimalist
because they didn't own anything anymore
now they as a family sort of worked
together
got past the anxiety and we're actually
a better family because of it quite
often
we have these these tragedies these
pivot points these inciting incidents
that
that are really really difficult in the
moment the car crash kind of thing
but it reminds me of that you know matt
nathanson the uh
the singer-songwriter yeah uh he's got a
song about the lyric in the chorus is i
want to feel the car crash i want to
feel it capsized
and and sometimes we do need to blow
something up so
metaphorically right like i need to just
blow up the entire now you get to make
that choice if you're making the choice
you're doing so intentionally and and
sometimes it's going to be easier to let
go if you make that decision
and someone as opposed to someone else
making that decision for you well here's
the thing too is carissa knows i mean
she obviously knows she has to get rid
of some of her things she cannot take
everything to california
so whenever we make the right choices in
our lives even though it's difficult
even though it might be hard
even though we feel that angst of of
making these hard decisions whenever we
actually do make the right choice
right i mean hands down we feel more at
peace in our minds and our hearts
yeah so carissa you know what you got to
do yes you have to make these decisions
and yes
if you make the right decisions and you
do it deliberately yes you will feel
calmer you will feel freer you will not
experience as much
as anxiety you will release that anxiety